momento de conocer cuáles son las
principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y para eso nos acompaña por
supuesto nuestro compañero jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches vamos a comenzar
en mexico el banco de este país elevó la
tasa de interés al 5 por ciento y lo
hizo en medio de un alto nivel de
inflación verdad así que bueno la junta
de gobierno del banco central de ese
país aprobó la nueva tasa con una
votación en el que cuatro integrantes
apoyaron la nueva tasa y sólo uno de
ellos votó en contra este es el cuarto
aumento consecutivo de 25 puntos base
del objetivo en medio de la inflación
más alta desde 2017 desde junio el banco
de mexico que es conocido como banxico
ha mantenido el aumento para los costos
de endeudamiento como un esfuerzo para
desacelerar la inflación que se
encuentra superior al 6% después de que
la economía mexicana se desacelerará
durante el tercer trimestre el banxico
se vio obligado a un movimiento de tasa
más agresivo como lo han hecho ya otros
bancos regionales economías como brasil
colombia chile también impulsaron
aumentos en las tasas el mes pasado
motivados por la inflación que tiene sus
raíces santiago
desde la cadena de suministros globales
vamos a hablar ahora del controversial
idiomas que como siempre sigue dando que
hablar ahora vendió las acciones de tela
como había prometido así es bueno en
total se deshizo de 45 millones de
acciones en lo que va de esta semana la
venta representa unos 5 mil millones de
dólares en acciones del fabricante de
autos eléctricos días después de
alimentar un gran debate en las redes
sociales sobre el tratamiento fiscal
para los multimillonarios y aunque hemos
mostró su iniciativa como si tuviera que
ver con el debate sobre la evasión de
impuestos de los millonarios documentos
publicados ayer muestran que algunas de
las transacciones ya estaban acordadas
desde mediados de septiembre semanas
antes de la encuesta en twitter box
tampoco mencionó que tiene millones de
opciones de compra de acciones que deben
realizarse antes de agosto del próximo
año cuando expiran esto según documentos
en manos de bloomberg las acciones de
teclas cayeron un 0.4 por ciento hasta
mil 63 dólares con lo que la caída de
esta semana asciende al 13 por ciento ya
jorge vamos ahora a viajar hasta corea
del sur- así se realizó lo que fue la
primera muestra de lo que será la
movilidad del futuro de qué estamos
hablando estamos hablando de taxi drone
es un proyecto gubernamental que se
espera estrenar en 2025 ese país
pretende además ser pionero en la
industria así como descarbonizar el
sistema de transporte se espera que los
vehículos voladores en un gran negocio a
nivel mundial en las próximas décadas
morgan stanley pronosticó que el mercado
mundial de aviones urbanos autónomos
podría alcanzar los 1500 millones de
dólares para el año 2040 veamos detalles
de este lanzamiento en el siguiente
reporte
un vistazo a la movilidad del futuro
corea del sur realizó una exhibición de
lo que será su sistema de control
vehicular de movilidad aérea urbana un
piloto voló el modelo de dos pasajeros
fabricados por la alemana voló cop ter
impulsado por rotores similares a los de
un helicóptero para despegues y
aterrizajes verticales el aparato puede
ser pilotado con o sin intervención
humana
nuestros motores y rotores tenemos 18 de
ellos así que si perdimos uno o dos no
importa y tenemos toda esta redundancia
en nuestro sistema completo y esto
proporciona seguridad para el pasajero
safety forecast desde el año pasado
corea del sur anunció un plan para
iniciar el transporte aéreo urbano
comercial en 2025 el ministerio de
transporte calcula que estos servicios
podrán hacer el tránsito más expedito el
tiempo de viaje de estas aeronaves puede
durar una tercera parte del traslado por
tierra
directos
se espera que la escala económica sea de
entre 700 y mil 700 billones de wones
creo que tendría un efecto económico de
más de 60 billones de wones teniendo en
cuenta el producto interno bruto de
corea del sur área de moneda
con esta apuesta según le espera ser
pionero en transformar la movilidad de
tierra a aire así como impulsar una
nueva economía basada en vehículos
eléctricos
bueno interesantísimo informe jorge
contanos ahora qué dicen los indicadores
de la jornada pero vamos con wall street
que cerró mixto aún con el impacto del
dato de la inflación presentado el
miércoles la tasa interanual se disparó
en octubre hasta el 6,2 por ciento en
europa la bolsa española descendió
afectada por las empresas energéticas y
turísticas y el pequeño retroceso de
wall street y en américa latina la bolsa
argentina cerró en positivo a la
expectativa de las elecciones cerramos
con la cifra del día 90 mil millones es
el valor de mercado de rubián la empresa
es la quinta fabricante de automóviles
más grande del mundo por capitalización
de mercado y la comparan mucho con tesla
gracias por esta nueva crónica hasta
aquí una completísima crónica económica
sigan y formándose en el resto de
nuestra programación gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]
i